one of y'all sent a fairly interesting
problem so I thought I would work it out
the problem is I have a group of 30
people so 30 people in a room they're
randomly selected 30 people 30 people
and the question is what is the
probability that at least at least two
at least two people have the same
birthday this is kind of a fun question
because you know I don't know that's the
size of a lot of classroom just what's
the probability that at least someone in
the classroom shares a birthday with
someone else in the classroom right and
that's actually another that's that's a
good way to phrase it well this is this
is the same thing as saying what is the
probability that someone shares with at
least someone else they could share it
with two other people or four other
people in the birthday someone someone
some not once someone else all right and
at first this problem seems really hard
because wow there's a lot of
circumstances that make this true
I could have exactly two people have the
same birthday I could have exactly three
people have the same birthday
I could have exactly twenty nine people
have the same birthday all of these make
this true so do I add the probability of
each of those circumstances and then add
them up and then that becomes really
hard and then I would have to say okay
whose birthday is am i comparing and I'd
have to do combinations it becomes a
really difficult problem unless you make
kind of one very simplifying I would say
take on the problem this is the opposite
of let's let me draw the the probability
space let's say that let's say that this
is all of the outcomes let me draw it
with a thicker line we draw a thicker
line let me draw it so let's say that's
all of the outcomes in my probability
space so that's a hundred percent of the
outcomes and we want to know we want to
know let me we want to know let me draw
it in a color that won't be offensive to
you now that doesn't look that great but
anyway let's say that this is the
probability this this area right here I
don't know how
it really is we'll figure it out let's
see that this is the probability that
someone shares a birthday with at least
someone else right what's this area over
here what's this green area
well this that means if these are all
the cases where someone shares a
birthday with someone else
these are all the area where no one
shares a birthday with anyone no one
shares with anyone or you could say all
30 people have different birthdays have
different birthdays all right so we're
trying to figure out this is what we're
trying to figure out the probability
I'll just call it the probability that
you know someone shares I'll call it the
probability of sharing probability of s
this is the problem this is one if this
whole area is area one or area 100% this
green area right here this is going to
be one minus P of s right this is going
to be one minus P of s or if we said
that this is the probability or another
way we could say actually this is the
best way to think about it if this is
different so this is the probability of
different birthdays this is the
probability that all 30 people have 30
different birthdays right no one shares
with anyone the probability that someone
shares with someone else plus the
probability that no one shares with
anyone they all have distinct birthdays
that's got to be equal to one because
we're either going to be in this
situation we're going to be in that
situation or you could say they're equal
to 100% either way 100 percent and 1 are
the same number is equal to 100% so if
we figure out the probability that
everyone has the same birthday we could
subtract it from 100 so let's see if we
could we could just rewrite this the
probability that someone shares a
birthday with someone else that's equal
to 100 percent minus the probability
that everyone has distinct separate
birthdays and the reason why I'm doing
that is because as I started off in the
video this is kind of hard to figure out
you know I can figure out the
probability that people have two people
have the same birthday five people and
it becomes very confusing but he
if I want to just figure out the
probability that everyone has a distinct
birthday it's actually a much easier
probability to solve for so what's the
probability that everyone has a distinct
birthday so let's think about it
person 1 person 1 let's let's just for
simplicity let's imagine the case that
we only have two people in the room
what's the probability that they have
different birthdays so if I have to
print let's see person 1 their birthday
it could be 365 days out of 365 days in
the year right you know whatever their
birthday is and then person to how many
if we wanted to ensure that they don't
have the same birthday how many days
could person to be born on well it could
be born on any day that person 1 was not
born on so there's 364 possibilities out
of 365 so if you had two people the
probability that no one is born on the
same birthday this is just 1 is just
going to be equal to 360 for 364 over
365 right now if we had what happens if
we had three people so first of all the
first person could be born on any day
then the second person could be born on
364 possible days out of 365 and then
the third person what's the probability
that this third person isn't born on
either of these people's birthdays so
two days are taken up so the probability
is 363 over 365 so this is equal to you
multiply them out you get 365 times 360
actually I should rewrite this one
instead of saying this is 1 let me write
this as the numerator is 365 times 364
over 365 squared because I want you to
see the pattern right here the
probability is 365 times 364 times 363
over 365 to the third power and so in
general if you just kept doing this 230
if I just if
you know if I just kept this process to
430 people so 30 people the probability
that no one shares the same birthday
would be equal to 365 times 364 times
363 will have off 30 terms up here right
all the way down to what 330 all the way
down to 336 right that'll actually be 30
terms divided by 365 365 to the 30th
power and you can just type this into
your calculator right now it'll take you
a little time to type in 30 numbers and
you'll get the probability that no one
shares the same birthday with anyone
else but before we do that let me just
show you something that might make it a
little bit easier is there any way that
I can mathematically Express this with
factorials or that I could
mathematically Express this with
factorials let's think about it
365 factorial is what 365 factorial is
equal to 365 times 364 times 360 3 times
all the way down to 1 right just keep
multiplying it's a huge number now if I
just want the 365 times the 364 in this
case I have to get rid of all of these
numbers back here so what I would one
thing I could do is I could divide this
thing by all of these numbers so 363
times 362 all the way down to 1 so
that's the same thing as dividing by 360
3 factorial right 365 factorial divided
by 360 3 factorial is essentially this
because all of these terms cancel out
right so this is equal to 365 factorial
over 363 factorial over 365 squared and
of course for this case it's almost
silly to worry about the factorials but
it becomes useful once we have something
larger than 2 terms up here so by the
same logic this right here is going to
be equal to 365
factorial over 362 factorial over 365
squared and actually just another
interesting point how did we get this
365 sorry how do we get this 363
factorial well 365 minus 2 is 363 right
and that makes sense because we only
wanted two terms up here we only wanted
two terms right here so we wanted to
divide by a factorial that's two less
right and so we'd only get the highest
two terms left so this this is also
equal to you could write this as 365
factorial divided by 365 minus 2
factorial right 365 minus 2 is 363
factorial and then you just end up with
those two terms and that's that there
and then likewise this right here this
numerator you could rewrite as 365
factorial divided by 365 minus 3 and we
have 3 people factorial and that should
hopefully make sense right this is the
same thing as 365 factorial is 365
divided by 3 is 362 factorial and so
that's equal to 365 times 364 times 363
all the way down divided by 360 2 times
all the way down and that'll cancel out
with everything else and you'd be just
left with that and that's that right
there so by that same logic this top
part here this top part here can be
written as 365 factorial over what 365
minus 30 factorial and I did all of that
just so I can show you kind of the
pattern and because this is frankly
easier to type into a calculator if you
know where the factorial button is so
let's figure out what this entire
probability is so turning on the
calculator we want so let's do the
numerator 365 factorial
/ well what's 365 - 30 that's 335 right
/ 335 factorial and that's the whole
numerator and now we want to divide the
numerator divided by 365 to the 30th
power let's calculate or think and we
get point 2 9 3 6 equals 0.2 9 3 6 it
keeps good actually 3 7 if you round it
which is equal to twenty nine point
three seven percent now just so you
remember what we were doing all along
this was the probability that no one
shares a birthday with anyone right this
was this was the probability of everyone
having distinct different birthdays from
everyone else and we've said well the
probability that someone shares a
birthday with someone else or maybe more
than one person is equal to all of the
possibilities kind of 100% the
probability space - the probability that
no one shares a birthday with anybody so
that's equal to 100% - twenty nine point
three seven percent what another way you
could write it as that's you know one -
point two nine three seven which is
equal to so if I want to subtract that
from one one - that just means the
answer the that means one minus point
two nine you get point seven zero six
three so the probability that someone
shares a birthday with someone else is
0.7 oh six three it keeps going which is
approximately equal to 70 point six
percent which is kind of a neat result
because if you have 30 people in a room
you might say oh wow what are the odds
that someone has the same birthday as
someone else it's actually pretty high
most you know all seventy percent of the
time if you have a group of 30 people at
least one person shares a birthday with
at least one person one other person in
the room so that's kind of a neat
problem and and kind of a neat result at
the same time anyway see you in the next
video